okay thanks very much for the invitation
to speak this morning I'll tell you
about some work that my group has been
doing on special algorithms for learning
HMMs and uh another hidden type of
hidden Markov model called a tree hmm
this is working with my ex post doc
German song who is now in industry and
also some collaborators at UCSD Kamala
coterie and teaching Jung ok so the
overall goals of our work like much of
current research in genomics is to
interpret human genome wide Association
studies which to my mind have been
extremely successful over the last few
years in understanding the genetic basis
of many complex human diseases you see
here over here a schematic of all the
different significant snips in the human
genome which have been associated
reproducibly with complex disease and
you see it basically covers the entire
genome and so what a lot of the field is
doing now is to pursue follow-up studies
of these disease low sigh and to really
try to advance personalized medicine in
this way by understanding a molecular
basis of this these disease snips as you
know most of the disease nips are not
actually in protein coding regions
they're actually in regulatory regions
and that really motivates our need to
annotate these regulatory regions of
genomes so the data will be using as
sort of the encode type data where you
have the input over here in grayscale
each track is a different histone mark
or chromatin mark for a particular cell
type shown in gray scale here so we'll
really be treating this as binary data
presence or absence of these histone
marks and the sequence is as usual the
human genome on the x-axis and what we'd
like to produce this an output sort of a
coloring of the genome into these
different blocks of colors a
segmentation of the genome for example
using a hidden Markov model where each
of these colors is going to represent
some kind of
underlying biological state such as a
enhancer promoter transcribed region or
so and you can see here one of the
reasons why there's different
segmentations is because there's
different cell types and so you can see
that same region of a genome could have
different functional significance in
different cell types unless you know
there's lots of data for this kind of
work there is the the encode project
which is done this for 147 cell types
and some other big projects that just
the roadmap epigenomics project but
we'll be looking at a later in the talk
so here's just a very broad overview of
our talk I'll be telling you about
spectral learning of hidden Markov
models that's a new sort of technical
area in machine learning this is where
we publish last year in genome biology
and then extend it later on to the case
of when you have multiple cell types
that's when the tree HMMs come in I'll
explain the graphical model later on but
you can think of it as a hidden Markov
model with a very large but structured
state space and that's work we published
recently in nips so pictorially I showed
you my inputs and outputs but let me
just try to be a little bit more clear
about that in words now so the input
will be a single long sequence and an
each position we're just going to be
given those gray scale inputs chromatin
marks each in the vertical axis as
simple think of that as a binary vector
yes please yes that's right isn't be a
binary vector for the purposes of
learning the parameters in the hidden
Markov model we're going to treat each
binary vector as a single character so
concretely if we have eight chromatin
marks then we'll have 2 to the 8
possible characters 256 possible
characters that's going to be our entire
universe of characters but just for the
purposes of display and only for the
purposes of displaying it in figures
i'll be showing you actually the
marginal probabilities of each component
in the vector
so I won't show you big admission
matrices where you have a 256 possible
probabilities it will actually just show
you eat we'll just take the marginal
over the components of that vector and
when we get to talk about multiple
sequences multiple related sequences
it'll be the same thing will have
multiple related sequences let's say
from different tissues or from different
cell types but we'll assume that are all
related by a fixed tree so we'll know
ahead of time what's the developmental
lineage for example of blood and we'll
know exactly how these cell types are
all related to each other the output
will just be the regular hmm outputs
parameters which will learn in an
unsupervised way and segmentation of the
sequence let's say that maximum
likelihood biter be parts of that
sequence into into these different
colors and similarly for tree hidden
Markov models
so as I said burner we're working in a
framework which is sort of become a
pretty big thing now in machine learning
it's called spectral learning so the
usual way people set up these hidden
Markov model unsupervised learning
approaches is to actually set this up as
a maximum likelihood problem and then to
run some kind of local search heuristics
such as expectation maximization being
the common one so there's lots of
different issues with e m and maximum
likelihood as we know one is simply that
it's slow usually takes a lot of
iterations it's a first order method and
the likelihood surface is typically not
a convex function um en is also only a
local search optimization methods so we
never guarantee getting the global
optimum and in certain cases as we know
the maximum likelihood can also be not
desirable criterion because it tends to
overfit the data it's an alternative way
to approach this problem is actually to
use actually an older statistical
framework called the method of moments
which is in some sense much more direct
than maximum likelihood we simply come
up with some empirical moments of the
data so think of the covariance or third
order moment and so on it and really try
to write that as a function of the
parameters and then solve those
equations to recover the parameters so
this has traditionally not been pursued
in the graphical model literature until
quite recently there turns out that if
you make very mild technical assumptions
on the structure of the graphical model
this turns out to be very efficient and
very quite straightforward to do so
we'll be able to learn hidden Markov
models using only a third order moments
so second and third moments the second
moment is going to be very simple we'll
just collect a matrix of counts of pairs
of consecutive observations along the
sequence so we're given a sequence of
numbers so
each number is going to be between 1 and
2 56 and I'll just have a 256 x 256
matrix that's my second order moment and
I'll just scan along the sequence and
for each pair of consecutive
observations I'm just going to increment
one cell in that 256 x 2 to 6 matrix and
i'm just going to count how many times i
observe each pair of observations so
it's extremely simple in one pass you'd
collect these statistics and you do the
similar thing for the third order moment
which is now going to be a third order
tensor a cube of numbers 256 x 256 x 256
x collect counts of triples of
observations so it's extremely simple um
at least the moments are and i will
write that won't have too many equations
in this i'll just say if this is a high
level but the second order moment is
going to be this p 1 2 matrix and the
third order tensor will be this p 1 2 3
a tensor this is the method of moments
so we're just going to take these
empirical counts and set them to be
equal to the expected moments of the
hidden Markov model distribution so this
is x we just declare these to be equal
and now the trick is to try to write
these moments in terms of the parameter
somehow and we really really want to get
it into some form that looks like this
where it's the sum over these elementary
Rank 1 matrices the sum has taken over m
hidden states and the idea is that if i
could factorize this if i could recover
the components of this sum then each of
those components would actually reveal
to me one column of my observation
matrix once we get recover the
observation matrix we would be able to
then recover the other parameters of the
hidden Markov model of transition
parameters and so on
so these w's you should think of them at
a high level I'm being a little sloppy
here and that's why I have distilled us
here think of that as something like the
initial state probably distribution
these are columns particular columns of
the observation matrix so that's the
conditional probability of observing
these 256 characters given that you're
in some particular hidden state okay so
morally speaking we should be able to
recover hidden Markov model parameters
just using these consecutive pairs of
observations because of the Markovian
property we should only we only look
back one step when we're when result
when we're doing these hidden Markov
models but obviously it's very hard to
recover this decomposition of the matrix
into these Rank 1 terms that the
composition in particular is not unique
unless you make additional additional
assumptions on these columns in
particular you could conceptually think
of the case where these columns of your
observation matrix are actually
orthogonal to each other it's a very
strange assumption from a statistical
standpoint because why should to
conditional probability vectors be
orthogonal to each other it's just a
mathematical construct but if they were
orthogonal to each other you would be
able to exactly and uniquely recover
this decomposition by doing a singular
value decomposition because that
decomposition would be unique once you
impose this orthogonality constraint we
don't want to make such a strong
assumption on the observation matrix and
that's why we have to go up to this
third order tensor so we do the same
thing over here and we can apply a
series of tricks the first one being a
kind of simple symmetrization step which
is not very interesting mathematically
or statistically so I'll just
say that we can actually come up with
some winter transformations to
symmetries the parison triples tensors
and then the main step is this of the
minion side is that you can use the
pair's matrix to actually orthogonal
eyes the triples tensor and what that
does is actually guarantees you that
there exists a unique orthogonal
decomposition of the triple sensor into
these into Rank 1 components where each
of those vectors is actually orthogonal
to each other so think of this as
something like PCA basically it's
essentially what's going on we're using
a correlation matrix that's the second
order moment to come up with a set of
orthogonal directions and we use that to
project the third order tensor or think
of that as the data we project the third
or cancer into those orthogonal
directions so this sort of PCA like step
or it's called whitening and statistics
kind of guarantees us that we have an
orthogonal decomposition and if you're
guaranteed that then there's a sort of
standard well okay so variations on
standard methods just the power method
where you can recover this orthogonal
tensor decomposition exactly okay so
that's a very high level overview of how
spectral learning works but the the
point of that being that we're now able
to compute these method of moments
estimators for hidden Markov models and
other related graphical models instead
of just maximum likelihood estimates
using the EML rhythm so yeah please
viewed as a superposition of processes
where all the variables are independent
within each process right all the
correlations are generated from taking
the taking this mixture
yes so you kind of make them independent
yeah so bye-bye playing with the second
and third moments you're able to kind of
make the third moment into it into a
mixture where those components are
independent and you what's the intuition
right other questions okay so we can
first ask how does this method do so
here's our implementation of this it's
called spectacle for spectral learning
so the first thing as you might expect
is it's much faster than the e/m
algorithm if you take a typical number
of states in genomics which is that say
20 chromatin states so that's a typical
number you see in the literature then
you could see that our learning time
would be about a hundred times faster is
that right yeah hundred times faster
then then chromhmm which is a connelly
used and the implementation of the EML
rhythm for this problem we've also
compared it to another program in the
literature called segue which is also
some version of a hidden Markov model a
much more complicated one but also using
the e/m algorithm and it took us about
five days to train the parameters i'll
show you that i'll show you that and in
much more detail just wait one more
slide for me now in terms of the
empirical sample complexity now this is
something which is a little bit more
interesting perhaps for learning
theorists so one nice thing about this
kind of special learning type methods is
that you can come up with sort of pact
style sample complexity bones and so
there are your theoretical guarantees
that the sample complexity the number of
sample points you need across your your
sequence is polynomial in all the
different parameters
theoretically it should depend on the
distribution of observations in the
genome so in particular you need to have
enough observations of sort of the least
common chromatin state right it's sort
of intuitive our data is parallel
distributed so we do see quite a lot of
observations even of the least common
chromatin state turns out that it has an
exponent of about 2 and this results in
a nice low theoretical complexity saml
complexity that's a theoretical result
empirically if anyone was thinking of
running this for any other kind of
sequence data in biology and kinder
Markov models obviously are kind of a
workhorse tool for lots of biological
sequences empirically what we found is
that prediction accuracy actually kind
of plateaus after using about fifty
percent of the human genome for training
so this is somewhat typical of method of
moments estimators that they're they
tend to be faster than maximum
likelihood estimators which is why a lot
of people use them but also that they
tend to need a lot of data to learn
those moments well and in our hands we
need about fifty percent of the human
genomes worth of data to actually learn
these third order tensor as well so if
you had something which was much smaller
than that sequence much smaller than
that we haven't done huge amount of
experiments but my intuition is that I
would probably not work so well and
maximum likelihood might be a more
robust way to actually go about solving
that please right
yeah so yeah so prediction of biological
features actually yeah so using some
kind of ground truth grout ground truth
data yeah I don't see how to do it
actually with you saying parameter
estimation yes we don't have a ground
truth parameter estimate to compare it
to yeah oh I guess you could do is
simulations but we haven't done that
yeah okay so let me get to Eric's
question which is about the actual
matrices so here's what we get from
spectral learning on the left is what
you get from expectation maximization
implemented in this program on the right
so this matrix is the number of
chromatin states on the y-axis there's
20 of them in this experiment typical
number for the literature but we've done
it with you know other other values of
of the number of chromatin states and
like i said i'm showing you these
observation matrices but i'm only
showing the marginal probabilities here
so as opposed to 256 long x axis that's
only an eight parameter long x axis it's
in grayscale so higher values like black
or close to probability 1 and white is 0
so the first thing eric is that the
predator estimates look pretty similar
if you look across you know we've we've
arranged note you know the learning
algorithm never tells you the order of
these states to we've we've matched them
up as best as possible to make it clear
that they look pretty similar but not
always so here's one which I've
highlighted over here where we learn
something that's different than what's
learned in the e/m solution or maximum
likelihood solution so over here what
they've learned is a kind of null state
where you have close to zero probability
for each of those chromatin marks and
it's not the only null state in this
observation matrix there's one here
there's one here and there's one up here
so they've learned three in all states
and this is no specific to
people who look at chromatin for a
living but if you have K for mono
methylation lo que 3 mano a mano k 3
methylation k4 trimethylation I'm sorry
no missing k for trimethylation and k27
acetylation this looks like a good
enhancer so what we're learning here is
some kind of enhancer state and what's
learned over here is some kind of null
or background state and this is
something we would expect from maximum
likelihood type methods which is that if
you have a classification problem where
you have a very large background state
it could be completely uninteresting but
in our case we have something like
ninety percent of the genome doesn't
make it above the threshold level of
chromatin marks so it's really kind of
in this null state then you could over
fit the the background state and end up
with lots of states just modeling the
background state and that doesn't happen
in this implementation in method of
moments because you have this kind of
orthogonal decomposition you know
character to the algorithms and that
really forces the algorithm to learn
sort of states which are different from
the previous previous one yes please
length of sequence what do you mean by
that the whole genome herbed this sorry
sort of scanning across the genome and
identifying for a given week
to this state yeah I'm not a hundred
percent sure what you're referring to
but I think it's so the resolution is
200 base pairs in this in this
experiment so forever tutored base pair
which is about the length of a nuclear
zone for every 200 base pair window
there's a binary vector of presents
absence of chromatin marks so stank 9 is
not an enhancer state it is probably an
enhancer state yep so what's the
difference between nine and twenty right
so let me show you that next so we can
actually now look at what what parts of
the genome are actually labeled let's
say in the Viterbi parts of the genome
with these different states and we can
actually in this experiment look at we
can look at lots of genomic roylott's
right we can look at the overlap with
promoters overlap with different types
of enhancer marks and so on and answer
data and so on what I'm showing you here
is going back all the way back to my gee
boss motivation which is that if we look
at the enrichment of jiwa snips or
disease associated variance in these
different in these different states then
in this plot more red is higher
enrichment so what we see here is
actually for these diseases and these
diseases are actually relevant to this
particular cell type which is a blood
cell type we see very high enrichment in
fact the highest enrichment across all
of the different states is in this new
enhancer state which we found and you
can compare that to nine or any of the
other ones and you see that it actually
has hired a nourishment than that one so
from a purely practical G was fine
mapping perspective I would say this is
a better state to use than nine if
you're trying to do enhancer predictions
and we've done this with lots of
different other genomic harlots eqtl
data hi-c
so on so we can tell these things apart
why if the color shows you the
enrichment yeah be like one enrichment
for state wise the color different for
each of the marks within the state yeah
these are not different marks these are
three different diseases sorry I'm sorry
yeah so this is a different plot so
these are three different diseases all
related to the blood cell type for each
disease we have enrichment for the g was
snips in that disease in these different
states please yeah yeah yeah so I should
somebody asked me that recently so it's
not very small it's not very small it's
not it's you know so it's within a
factor of two or three of the what
chromhmm would predict us an enhancer I
mean it's oh you know half or one third
of that but it's not you know a
vanishingly small fraction I mean you
can think of it if you want to as rope
you know so we have more states
essentially them chromhmm right because
they have more in all states so you can
take think of it as their enhancer calls
will be split into several sort of sub
enhancers that we would predict in those
those fractions are not vanishingly
small it's like maybe 40 to 60 sorry
20 yeah
right right right right so it's not one
hundred percent but they assign them
mostly yes or something like stay at
nine so you can something like say 90
100 percent but you know a gross gross
levels of the next eight nine so you can
think of it as state nine of Chrome hmm
has been split into our save nine in our
state 20 but our state 20 has hired
measurements so that's a more specific
prediction and it's not a vanishingly
small one so it's not you know one
percent it's like forty percent
something like that but I should get
that exact number because is that this
answer OIC se SI no no no no they're not
because so this this assignment of the
two states is just something we do by
hand right so it's yeah we've just line
them up for visual purposes but the
algorithm does something in the back
yeah yeah we haven't done too many
experiments with that so I'm sorry but
yeah I don't have a lot of used to say
bye yeah so for half for the purposes of
comparing we do the same thing as
chromhmm because we're trying to keep
that step the same so the yeah so it's a
kind of literature published method yeah
it's a Poisson distribution and they
threshold the person was there another
way you please same question so some of
these states if you go to the last slide
should look the same last slide okay
like in terms of their comment system
right look different to the question in
C and say are these the same really
things these the same locations that
commission member signs that state like
well I mean not not not exactly rice
because not not exactly the same because
well if some of these regions over here
were in this solute in our special
learning solution were now assigned to
this new state and they would not just
meet you know in the old state nine or
whatever so they would yeah you might
get a lower enrichment in that is
address it's not exactly it's not
exactly you know rc9 is not exactly
there stay nine right it's i'm
understanding a very gross high-level
sense if the emissions look similar in
the previous slide yeah expect the
locations that are assigned to be the
same not yeah but not one hundred
percent right because you know it's a
you're doing a fighter be parsed then
you have to kind of decide which is the
best stage good you go to a different
one
okay and you're so right so we've done a
lot of other things other than G was
slippin Richmond i can't remember Eric
was asking then a lot of other genomic
Laura let's like eqtl and high C and so
forth so we're fairly confident that
these states really are sort of
different enhancers at least you know be
some correlations back to a statistical
thing if you wanted to you don't have to
actually just use the method of moments
estimator you could use it as a
initializer to a local search algorithm
such as a.m. and we've done that on some
data sets and that sometimes does give
us better likelihoods for you see this
blue picture a blue plot there's
sometimes we can actually get to a
higher likelihood if that's what you're
trying to do and for some data sets you
might actually like to really try to
optimize the likelihood for example if
you don't have this class imbalance
problem if you really have balance data
maximum likelihood might actually be the
criterion to optimize and sometimes do
see that the higher likelihood does
actually translate into higher precision
recall accuracy for example for
promoters in is it right for okay I'd
put in here but I think this is for
promoters so I'm running a bit slow but
I'm have two minutes huh all right so
let me at least tell you the model of
our paper so with a hidden Markov model
you have just one sequence which this
white balls with the shaded balls been
your observations so our model is has
been called the tree hmm in the
literature and now you're given a fixed
tree so think of this as being for
example some a fetal brain region we're
quite interested in brain diseases so
we're looking at brain data lots a fetal
brain and then some adult brain regions
the tree can be an arbitrary sized
I'm just showing a size 3 tree here so
now the assumption that's being embedded
in this graphical model is that if
you're an enhancer you're more likely to
be an enhancer at a particular position
in the genome if the previous position
is in that enhancer as always with the
hidden Markov model but also if the
parental cell type or tissue is in an
enhancer so the tree lineage is what's
embedded here we have some algorithmic
ideas written up in our nips paper the
main one being this thing which we call
the skeleton sir so this is a new sort
of thing in spectral learning where what
we're able to do is actually avoid
constructing a very very large tensor
which is exponential in the in the
number of cell types so we want to avoid
that kind of large tensor and we want to
really project that into a very small
canceller which is back to the size of
just one node in the tree one cell type
and we call that the skeleton sir and so
with the Scimitar ization step that i
mentioned in the in the sort of my
overview of spectral learning we've
completely changed that to be able to
also do this projection step as well so
this is sort of at a high level the main
technical contribution of our paper you
put our ideas together we have an
algorithm which overall solves this
graphical model well when the tree has
low depth and I'd like to argue that for
most biological data sets low depth
trees are the common thing for example
if you think about my brain example you
typically don't have very large very
long time courses where you're able to
really ask say the same person over a
very long period of time you typically
have something like fetal brain and then
another time point which is adult brain
regions but you have many many brain
regions they really slice the brain into
lots of different regions so we'd have a
very shallow depth depth to tree but a
very wide tree and that's exactly when
our methods work well we've
compared it extensively to a variational
expectation-maximization method which
has been published in the literature and
it has some additional some additional
statistical and also biological
constraints on it to try to make it
tractable in this case took them about
13 hours to run on a Saturday to set and
are stick about 22 minutes so that's the
same thing as I said before it's our
methods are much more fast and we have
sort of similar behavior as before
here's in a picture of the observation
matrices again where you see that the
maximum likelihood solution grossly over
fits the background and you have lots of
white over here so that's a lot of
background states and over here we see
what hap to go into the biology but lots
of interesting biological states here's
a pic here's another comparison where we
can ask if the tree model if adding the
tree actually helps us over just
considering you to the cell types
individually and we see that in general
except for this one case where we think
we can explain that away in general we
do see a bump in prediction accuracy for
biological features
and also just mention very quickly that
we can also learn cell type-specific
emission parameters very briefly in
embryonic stem cells we see enhancers
which are poised as opposed to other
adult stem cells where they have adult
cell types where they have this h3k27
acetylation and are active so there's
some more biological insights to be
gained from from this method so I'll
just this is my last slide I just want
to say very quickly why I I think
spectra learning is particularly
well-suited for genomics one is that we
have very large sample sizes in genomics
so that means that efficient algorithms
are actually needed to to learn these
models and the flip side actually we
have enough samples to learn these kinds
of method of moments estimators
biological interpretability so this is
to answer the question which people now
ask a lot which is why don't you use
deep learning and the reason for that is
because we found that simple models such
as hidden Markov models actually do seem
pretty close to the biology we actually
are able to get a lot of biological
insight from them so parameter
estimation and interpretation is
actually very important for us we don't
just want to do prediction and also this
last empirical observation they made
which is that these methods seem very
robust to class imbalance and that seems
to be a pervasive tuning in genomics as
well okay thanks very much
thank you there was lots of discussion
already I mean yeah nine questions when
you use the special solution to initiate
the yen algorithm Fred when the end
proceeds does it converge to state that
nation yeah so so that particular thing
I showed was for a balanced data set
we're actually it is keeping the
information they set in this in the
States but if you did running on
inbounds data set and it would start to
go toward zero yeah
it's thank you a speaker again